en ce qui concerne la justesse de nos souvenirs
que nous savons être justes, que nous croyons.
Il existe des décennies de recherche,
une multitude d'exemples d'affaires comme celle-ci,
où les individus
croient vraiment. Aucun des adolescents
qui l'avaient identifié,
ne pensait qu'il désignait la mauvaise personne.
Aucun ne pensait qu'il n'avait pas pu voir le visage de la personne.
Nous devons tous faire très attention.
Tous nos souvenirs sont reconstruits.
Ils sont le produit de ce que nous avons vécu initialement
et de tout ce qui c'est passé après.
Ils sont dynamiques.
Ils sont malléables. Ils sont volatiles,
et en conséquence, nous devons tous nous rappeler d'être prudents,
et que la réalité de nos souvenirs
ne se mesure pas à leur vivacité
ni au degré de certitude de leur exactitude.
Merci. (Applaudissements)